been discussing your colleague Boris
Johnson do you hope they will join your
campaign well look actually I think
that's a decision for him to make and
you know I feel firm right now with a
lot of the speculation that's taking
place because I can only speak from my
own personal position you know coming to
the decision that I have come to as well
it is difficult it is absolutely
difficult and it's one that you can only
make yourself on the basis of what you
really believe in when it comes to
Britain's place in Europe but as
Britain's place in the world and of
course that's something that Boris
Johnson's gonna have to work out himself
but you always believed it didn't I have
done I've been you know I'm quoted I'm
on the record I said you know 20 years
ago I was campaigning for a referendum
and I have to say I think there is a
great tribute to be paid to David
Cameron as the conservative prime
minister
so there's done exactly what our
conservative manifesto said it would do
which was to deliver the British public
that referendum I mean in terms of what
he's you know we we saw there that the
sleepless nights and the hours he put in
in Brussels you said before he went
there that he it was a waste of time he
was going naked into the conference
chamber well what I'd say about the
renegotiation he has invested a lot of
time and effort he has been determined
and steadfast in that renegotiation I
pay tribute to him on that I really do I
personally believe this is the best deal
that he was able to get and you know
he's his role now I mean he's very clear
about this as he went into those
renegotiations as well that he was
starting from that position that he
wanted to stay in the European Union and
he wanted to get a new settlement to
then campaign to stay in the European
Union but Barca very intriguing or
saying about that you've seen four
enough he's been clear about that and
I've got utmost respect for him for that
I really Jenna I think he's conducted
himself
incredibly well throughout this
renegotiation I mean getting the deal
you saying all that and of course so you
should I mean he's been very good to you
hasn't he during the course of your he's
honest
yeah well and indeed and has promoted
you within within the party within the
government gee we do not feel a bit this
I have to say I mean coming to the
decision that I have done it's you know
it's not an easy one to make and I am
you know it has been uncomfortable as
well in making that decision
but this is a position that I firmly
believe in you know I've started off
saying as well I've got long-standing
long-held views on Europe the
institutions of Europe fundamentally as
well though I have always believed there
has been a Democratic deficit as well in
Britain's relationship with the European
Union and that's why it's important we
have this referendum we have a
conservative prime minister that has
delivered this referendum or will be
delivering the referendum on June the
23rd it's not up to us though as
politicians I firmly believe that I've
said this for many many years the
British public should decide it is their
referendum which is why I don't think
it's about politicians and political
personalities at all I think ultimately
this referendum will bring forth the
arguments the public will be able to
decide and rightly so it is their choice
in their decision the question in this
referendum is pretty binary we're either
in or we're out and that's a choice that
people will have to make and this is a
binary choice about the Prime Minister's
future me would you feel any regret if
altom utley we don't know how the
campaign will pan out we obviously don't
know the result but if it does
ultimately end the Prime Minister's
career our Prime Minister is here to
stay let's be very clear about this this
is real revel this is a referendum that
the Conservative Party are delivering we
stated that in our manifesto very
clearly this is not about the future of
David Cameron which should be absolutely
clear about this this is a referendum
that he and our government have given to
the British public the public will
decide as to which where we go he
himself said everyone in as well when he
was on television he will conduct the
wishes of the British public with
whatever the decision do his best but
you know in his heart he wants to stay
in the European can you get the result
you want would you seem as the best man
to dismantle the UK's relation he is our
prime minister and he is here he will
stay I'm absolutely convinced about that
and I don't think this is about that
I've said this is about Europe and
Britain's relationship with you this is
not about David Cameron and this isn't
about politicians on which way they are
going to go either
so I mean you say it's interesting you
say it's not about personalities you're
very relaxed then about George Galloway
being on your side of the campaign
well actually I'm George Galloway has
his own views but at the end of the day
this is for the British
- man you got to have it you know
articulating the argument to leave your
I think let's be clear about this there
are a wide range of personalities and
individuals associated with both
campaigns they will make they will make
their points and that's up to them but
ultimately this is for the British
public to decide and I should just say
as well I don't think it is for
politicians to be overstating their
roles and their positions and their
poise I have firmly said and I believe
this as well that but far too long
successive governments have lectured the
British public in terms of Europe and
the direction of travel successive
governments and at the same time
successive governments have denied the
British public a voice and they're say
when it comes to Britain's relationship
with the European Union so I put this
down I trust the British public I trust
the people to decide and we will go
ultimately with the choice and decision
on the people that articulate the
campaign's on both sides you've just all
relatively recently won the unexpected
majority in the general election and
you're the mastermind behind the
campaign Linton Crosby cuts of the
quick-set it's very simple it's about
leadership our leaders better than their
leader Ed Miliband at the time it was
about personalities the British public
made their decision partly on the basis
of who they thought was best placed to
take us through the future I think and
you've been on this program talking to
me about how David Cameron was was the
right man and now it doesn't matter who
leads this is very different to general
election you know leadership of your
country more binary choice you just said
well this is this is a binary choice in
the referendum question itself whether
or not we stay in or leave the European
Union the two kept the two campaigns
will articulate the case they will make
the points over the next 124 days and
during that time of the campaign
throughout the country this isn't just a
you know the media and the Westminster
bubble as well talking about the issues
that matter around Britain's
relationship with Europe and our place
in the world this will be for the public
to decide they themselves no side of the
campaign's you think it's it's fine to
have so many different leave campaigns
grassroots out leave dot it'll be a
designation I believe there will be a
designated elected by the Electoral
Commission so I mean are you saying that
it is in poor
to have a very clear message articulated
by a few people at the top or it doesn't
matter we can have the Tower of Babel it
doesn't matter no I take the view very
clearly of course sponsor into the
designated campaign period and the very
group is designated and has its official
role I don't what I'm saying is I don't
think the voice will be just that of
politicians there will be business
voices there'll be members of the public
from around the country as well you know
as I've said this isn't a London on the
southeast referendum this is a
nationwide campaign and ultimately this
is the choice for Britain to decide
which is why having the wide ranges of
voices which are not dominated by
politicians I think is incredibly
important and are you saying that when
it comes to business leaders with their
degree of information with some insider
knowledge EU got some some big beasts
you think to come out of I welcome all
business voices to this debate and I
don't think it's about big business I
should watch this space no it's not
about business or it's about almost we
watch this space I believe got some
inside info we should you know this is
we're at the start of a campaign right
now they'll be many voices that will
come to the table and express their
views and that's exactly what we should
expect you in the campaign and when it
comes to businesses I don't think this
campaign should be dominated by the
voice of big business or corporate
voices there are plenty of small
businesses out there I'm not in my
constituency alone 85% of my
constituents are employed by SMEs those
SME speak to me about Europe a lot so
there'll be a range of voices in this
camp do you think more more members of
your own party are here someone from the
Whip's office is about to to declare a
more senior man my own personal sense is
that there are many of my colleagues
that have long held views on Europe and
Britain's relationship with the European
Union they will I'm sure you know
express themselves over the next few
days as well let me ask you this I mean
as as a unionist with it with a small
you and it was articulated again today
it's been pretty explicit from the
Scottish National Party for a long time
that if the result you want is achieved
for the United Kingdom to leave the EU
then Scotland if it did vote
individually to remain within the
European Union there would be grounds
for for another referendum on Scottish
independence would you see it as a price
worth paying the breakup of the United
Kingdom
you get UK muster out of the EU I mean
first of all I mean when it comes to
Britain leaving the European Union I
don't think we should talk ourselves
down one bit at all I'm an
internationalist and I believe that we
have a lot that we can do in terms of
growing our country our economy and
flourishing outside of the European
Union so let me start with that point as
well I heard Scotland is very different
actually because the Scottish journey
has evolved since the independence
referendum let's be clear about that
we've had the Smith Commission there are
discussions taking place in government
right now still in terms of delivering
the Smith Commission we have the
Scotland bill so you know delivering
Smith is absolutely the priority of this
government and I think that is the
current focus it's not about speculating
about a future referendum or what will
come afterwards the focus of this
government quite rightly is working with
the Scottish Government on devolve in
the powers that the Smith Commission
very clearly stated should be devolved
that is the discussion that is taking
place today this isn't about a future
discussion on future referendum but a
Scots army the First Minister is
explicit that depending on the outcome
there may well be strong grounds for
another reference
well she's speculative independent she
also has her own questioning is
speculating that the acronym or
reference look what's up what we do with
it I think that we should assert a new
church what you do we should also make
the case as well and make the point that
in Scotland alone they have their own
elections this year - and at the same
time you know that against the backdrop
of delivering the Smith Commission as
well which is incredibly important for
the government here in Westminster but
also for the Scottish government as well
that is the focus right now okay pretty
retail very good to see thank you very
much indeed and you don't to lead one of
these campaigns just go to us I'm here
as a supporter and a voice for the out
campaign one of the many voices ok very
good to see you thank you very much
indeed